okay so it's a number file video we
should do something with numbers I've
got a blackboard here so we'll just
bring this up
now the first thing I'd like to do is
show you a very nice very quick
wonderful number trick ah excellent some
brown paper okay so for this number
trick what you do is you take any one
digit number so for example our O'Brady
what what one digit would you like six
lovely number six so you write down the
number six that's the digit you picked
and then you write it down two more
times to get a three digit number so in
this case 666 and then what you do is
first of all you work out what the sum
of those three digits are so in this
case 6 plus 6 is 12 plus 6 is 18
so we're I to add them up I would get 18
as a total and now I'm going to divide
666 by that total by a team and that
equals so if I put in six six six and
then divide that by 18 it equals 37 okay
so you happen to pick six three sixes
divided by the sum of those sixes equals
37 and the reason this counts as a
number trick is before we started I
predicted that the total would be 37 in
fact this is the video unsurprisingly
about 37 and that will work for any
number you care to choose in fact oh
sure I will show you why that works so
let's get this out there this is getting
a bit silly writing on paper we'll get
that out of the way
ah Malthus okay so I'll show you why
that works bring this up so when you
pick any number so you pick six or let's
do seven instead let's say right when
you write something like seven seven
seven what you're actually doing is that
is exactly the same as seven times 111
also whatever your one digit number
happens to be it's that times 111 and
when you add the three digits together
well what you're doing there is you're
just doing whatever your digits times
three because there's going to be three
of them so in fact that bit there where
I divided in your case 666 divided by 18
or here I'll divide 777 by 21 what I've
actually got
seven times one one one over seven times
three and these cancel out and you're
left with 111 divided by three which is
37 so every single time you do it it's
whatever the number is times 1 1 1
divided by whatever the number is times
3 please cancel out it's always 111
divided by 3 which equals 37